a Rock's defense minister said this
morning that US troops that were pulled
out of Syria will leave Iraq in four
weeks now that seems to contradict US
defense secretary Marquez / who made a
surprise visit to Baghdad this morning
Esprit previously said those US forces
would continue operating against Isis
from Iraq Russia and Turkey made a deal
yesterday without the u.s. to take
control of northeastern Syrian force out
Kurdish fighters who fought alongside US
troops this morning Holly Williams is in
Syria where she has exclusive access to
Turkish forces that have crossed the
border just three weeks ago Kurdish LED
forces allied with the u.s. were in
control of this territory here in
northeastern Syria now Turkey is in
control this is the Turkish military
Turkish soldiers we came across the
border with them this morning it has
been a tumultuous time earlier this
month the president Trump ordered US
troops to pull back from the
turkey-syria border American forces are
now withdrawing from eastern Syria
following that turkey launched an
offensive into northeastern Syria
targeting those Kurdish forces that were
partnered with the u.s. in the fight
against Isis but Turkey regards them as
a terrorist organization last night we
saw Turkey's president reject a year for
her Dewan and Russian President Vladimir
Putin making a deal about the future of
this part of Syria they agreed on a
ceasefire turkey will get a nearly 20
mile deep safe zone along its border and
Turkish soldiers will carry out joint
patrols with Russian troops we've
already seen Russian troops moving into
areas that were controlled by Kurdish
forces backed by the US all of this is a
powerful illustration of how the u.s. is
ceding influence here in the Middle East
to Russia
now those Kurdish led forces say that
they are still holding around 12,000
accused Isis fighters including 4,500
foreigners and one big question going
forward is who will take control of
those prisons who will stop a mass
prison break who will prevent Isis
reforming its army of militants Thank
You Holly